good morning believe nation today's
message is necessity is the mother of
invention over to you Robert Noyce
necessity they say is the mother of
invention
we have a lot of necessity in our
society today and I think the time is
here for inventing new approaches new
solutions to these various problems so
that we can indeed maintain America and
indeed the rest of the world as well as
the land of opportunity for all of those
who will be the achievers of the future
I love this message and one that I can
really resonate with because as
entrepreneurs we solve problems that's
what we do that's what we're good at
right there's a problem there's
something that needs to be solved and we
are the ones who fill that void who
solved the problem for ourselves and for
our clients and we need to be creative
and different and think outside the box
and come up with a solution that hasn't
been offered before we're trying to make
our name in the marketplace are trying
to stand out from our competitors and
it's gonna come from doing things that
are different and quite often it comes
from scratching your own itch from
having a problem in your life then you
solve for yourself and then sell it to
others because if you're having that
problem chances are other people are as
well it can be something as little as
you know I wanted a t-shirt about the
little man and so I made this this came
out of a creation this is something that
that Jay Rhys helped me design I wanted
to have a different background here in
the wall my old videos used to be me on
a on a white background just against my
wall and I thought you know what I gotta
have some branding on it so I painted
the wall block and I've got this huge
sticker made of my logo when I put the
BKA calendar on here right and that's
serve the purpose those are all small
examples we go a little bit bigger why
did I create the N special series why
did I create the top-ten series because
I needed it because it was selfish
so scratching my own itch because nobody
else had done anything close and I
needed to start my day with some people
to push me to think bigger and be the
best version of myself that's why I
started it and I'm sharing it with you
guys and you're enjoying it as well and
so look at the biggest problems that
you're facing in your life look at the
problems of the people around you and
start solving them that could be a
potential business for you necessity is
the mother of invention entrepreneurs
are the people who are gonna solve the
little problems in the world and the big
problems of the world you want to solve
world peace you want to solve the
economy you want to solve major diseases
you want to solve humanitarian issues
it's all gonna be in my view through
entrepreneurship so the question of the
day today is I want to know what problem
you have solved recently big or small
what's the most recent problem that
you've solved I'm really curious to find
out dig a little deeper into your lives
leave a comment below and I'm gonna join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso